we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save
twenty percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman steadymd lets
you maintain a meaningful long
lasting relationship with the primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started i actually have
some good news to start with today
we have been sort of worried that not
enough people
in the united states in other countries
as well but we've been looking at the
numbers in the united states that not
enough people in the u.s would want the
coronavirus vaccine
which would make it really difficult to
get to the herd immunity
that is necessary for life to
really start going back to normal in the
context of the pandemic but the good
news
is that every single week the percentage
of americans that want the vaccine
and plan to get the vaccine and would
accept the vaccine
where it made available to them is going
up and that's excellent
that number is now at 71 percent 71
of americans say they would get the
vaccine and remember that
just months ago only 40 percent of
americans wanted it and that crept up
to 50 60 63
about a month and a half ago and that
number is now at 71
and the poll that shows 71 percent
is from before joe biden and dr
anthony fauci received their first doses
over the last 36 to 48 hours
which hopefully will push interest in
getting the vaccine up even
further now the 27 percent
that remain hesitant about this vaccine
um there's a few characteristics these
are a few different groups so
those who remain vaccine skeptical are
disproportionately
republicans disproportionately those
30 to 49 and disproportionately people
who live
rurally uh and disproportionately
uh black american who who are the most
vaccine
hesitant groups now the reasons why
each of these groups is hesitant about
the vaccine differ
um some of the primary reasons are
fear of side effects fear that the
vaccine is
too new which can mean a lot of
different things but that that's the way
they described it
and among among black americans the
primary reasons for vaccine coronavirus
vaccine hesitancy
are general distrust of vaccines
and concerns that one could get
coronavirus
from the coronavirus vaccine now in
terms of
states i don't this is not super
surprising but there's some interesting
data points here based on data from the
ihme from a few days ago
the states where residents most want the
vaccine
are vermont new york minnesota
washington state california hawaii
virginia and colorado followed closely
by
sort of the rest of the northeast states
plus north carolina and a few others now
on the other side of this
the states where residents least want
the vaccine
at the absolute bottom of the list are
mississippi arkansas
and wisconsin now i'm guessing that
there are
particulars about why wisconsin is there
i don't know if maybe
wisconsin has a number of different
religious uh groups and sects there
i don't know if there's one that is
overwhelmingly anti-vaccine
i'd be interested in knowing more about
that but mississippi arkansas and
wisconsin are the most uh the state's
most
at least interested in the coronavirus
vaccine followed by
um a number of states like texas south
carolina georgia alabama
ohio indiana oklahoma kansas so there's
quite a lot long list in sort of that
lower but not
lowest range so bottom line
it's good that the numbers are up to 71
percent i do want to remind you the
vaccine is not going to be given to kids
anytime soon
so when we talk about 70 for herd
immunity we're talking about the whole
country
so 71 of adults wanting and getting the
vaccine eventually
doesn't get us to 70 percent of the
entire country we still would not be at
heard immunity but these are the best
numbers we've had
since the start of this thing and that's
good um the public campaigns to say
i got the vaccine and people posting
pictures
on on facebook and social media dr fauci
getting the vaccine etc
that does seem to be working because
getting
a vaccine in the abstract before
anybody's getting it
um is not likely to appeal to as many
people as getting the vaccine that my 12
nurse friends got and posted on facebook
about
and that's certainly helping now as of
this morning
777 000 americans
have received the first dose of the
vaccine
that's 0.23 percent of the u.s
population
it's a start but again un unless and
we're expecting to
unless we ramp up the number of vaccines
going out and
and being used to inoculate people every
week
goes up it's going to take a while it's
going to be a process now in terms of
more vaccines remember that currently in
the u.s
there's the pfizer biontech vaccine and
the moderna vaccines that have been
approved
the moderna vaccine is just now starting
to be given to people
and then we have the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine close to possible approval
and then behind that you've got the
novovax and johnson and johnson vaccines
moving ahead
pending results so in the end whatever
the polls say
start distributing it get it to people
keep the process moving forward and
we'll keep evaluating month to month and
really week to week now an important
note and i don't understand
this yet i've seen the data i don't i
haven't interpreted the data um
even though states have now it's been
several days
and in fact more than that since uh
states received their first
shipments many states have only so far
actually used 10 to 15
of the vaccines that they've received
now i expressed concern
that we we don't want to see
lots of vaccines just sitting around and
not being used and a lot of this is
getting the logistics up and running and
i understand that
but over time if if we are seeing that
states are
sitting on a bunch of vaccine with lack
of clarity
or or or execution
in terms of actually getting it two
people that will be a concern and we'll
cross that that bridge
when we come to it but the urgency can't
be exaggerated another
3 400 people died yesterday of the virus
absolutely tragic numbers okay
uh this this story is a headache um
and there's just so much to talk about
so let's let's do it in detail and kind
of do it justice
donald trump surfaced from the hole in
which he's been hiding for weeks
yesterday
to deliver a four-minute speech about
the coveted relief package
which we deeply criticized yesterday for
its many flaws and its cronyistic
elements
and the i would say there's a two-sided
coin to donald trump's four-minute
speech
there's things i he said i agree with
and things that he said that i disagree
with
but it's actually much worse than that
it's like a four-sided coin
that you would be using on a chess board
while playing 4d chess i
i did i don't have a metaphor to really
explain
the erratic and confused nature of what
donald trump said yesterday so rather
than tell you
in advance let's just start going
through it some aspects of this uh
four-minute statement are completely
deranged
and at the same time donald trump
correctly said six hundred dollars per
person is not enough
i would like to see two thousand dollars
per person that's great
but this was still a wacky lie riddled
fiasco
so let's go through it all you will also
notice donald trump doesn't look or
sound good
slurring a lot that thing where he's
tripping over his tongue almost like his
teeth are too big or his tongue's
getting in the way worse than we saw
before the election so let's just jump
right into it we're gonna look at the
full four minutes
throughout the summer democrats cruelly
blocked coveted relief legislation
in an effort to advance their extreme
left-wing agenda
and influence the election so this is
already a lie i mean
democrats proposed more relief months
ago
before the summer mitch mcconnell said
we're not doing another relief bill
trump was m.i.a every once in a while
saying well
we're there's negotiation uh so so
that's just an absolute lie democrats
almost immediately after the first bill
we're proposing even including two
thousand dollars per month per month
like our friend ro khanna let's continue
then a few months ago
congress started negotiations on a new
package to get
urgently needed help to the american
people
it's taken forever however the bill they
are now planning to send back to my desk
is much different than anticipated it
really is
a disgrace for example among the more
than 5 000 pages in this bill
which nobody in congress has read
because of its length and complexity
it's called the coveted relief bill but
it has almost nothing to do with covert
okay now trump is correct
uh the bill is outrageously long
members of congress didn't have time to
read it and tons of it has nothing to do
with kovid
but it's not that the covet bill has
nothing to do with covid remember
they wrapped up together a funding of
government
bill and the covid bill 5500 pages and
were given everything to vote on
together so
trump trump is right that not there
wasn't enough time
but he's now starting to get into one of
the big deceptions of the speech let's
continue
this bill contains 85.5 million dollars
for assistance to
cambodia 134 million dollars to burma
1.3 billion dollars for egypt
and the egyptian military which will go
out and buy almost
exclusively russian military equipment
25 million dollars for democracy and
gender programs in pakistan
505 million dollars to belize costa rica
el salvador guatemala
honduras nicaragua and panama
40 million dollars for the kennedy
center in washington dc
which is not even open for business one
billion dollars for the smithsonian
and an additional 154 million dollars
for the national gallery of art
likewise these facilities are
essentially
not open seven million dollars for reef
fish
management 25 billion dollars to combat
asian carp
2.5 million dollars to count the number
of amberjack fish
in the gulf of mexico a provision to
promote the breeding of fish
in federal hatcheries three million
dollars in poultry production technology
two million dollars to research the
impact of downtrees
566 million dollars for construction
projects
at the fbi okay so so this this is
this is now where it goes completely off
the rails
um first of all trump only mentions
countries he doesn't care for
or or sort of like s-hole countries
countries he doesn't think we should
give money to
and he mentions climate and environment
related stuff that he also
doesn't care for and and i want to be
careful because this is two-sided
none of that stuff is part of the covid
bill
remember they had two bills together
this was like an
omnibus you had the funding of
government and you had kovid
and in the funding of government you
have aid and money designated for
different countries now
it's not really the covet bill does
trump know that
i don't know the answer to that there
are lots of people who
fell for the idea that a lot of these
things are in the covid bill when
they're not
trump could be lying in order to
make a political point or i don't know
but trump himself may not real like
trump may just be watching news max fox
whatever
and he may be falling for the idea that
the funding
is in the covet bill um
i i don't know i really don't know the
answer now
in fairness overall
when you look at the totality of what's
going on here uh donald trump
is simultaneously stumbling across
some important critiques of the system
like
trump doesn't this is it's so insane if
trump
instead of just saying we're giving
money to pakistan and for carp
or whatever if he were to say and and
and sort of say also mentioning
5 500 pages they didn't have time to
look at it if instead he said
these two bills shouldn't even be
together the coveted bill should be
simple it should be a standalone bill
it should have been shorter people
should have been able to it should have
been short enough that everybody can
actually look at it and then separately
deal with this other bill
that would be a really good critique of
how politics is done
instead trump goes almost into his
xenophobic stuff of listing countries we
shouldn't be giving money to
and then he builds on that by going into
the immigration stuff
the bill also allows stimulus checks for
the family members of illegal aliens
allowing them to get up to one thousand
eight hundred dollars each
this is far more than the americans are
given
now this is really deceptive
trump's claim is that americans get
six hundred dollars but illegal
immigrants get eighteen hundred dollars
that's just not true okay and and let's
see if i can explain this
what is true is that if you are a us
citizen or a legal permanent resident
with a green card
you get six hundred dollars and you get
the six hundred dollars
even if your spouse or partner is here
illegally
okay the spouse or partner doesn't get
six hundred dollars undocumented
immigrants don't get any money
you don't lose your six hundred dollars
if your spouse or partner is an
undocumented immigrant and
if you are here legally and you have
kids here
you get the six hundred dollars per kid
even if your spouse or partner
uh is an undocumented immigrant so so
trump saying
illegal immigrants get more money than
americans
is wrong in a bunch of different ways
the point is
being with an undocumented immigrant
does not preclude you as a legal citizen
or resident from getting six hundred
dollars for yourself
or the six hundred dollars per child
it's a completely
fabricated way to attack immigrants
let's continue despite all of this
wasteful spending
and much more the 900 billion
package provides hard-working taxpayers
with only
six hundred dollars each in relief
payments
and not enough money is given to small
businesses
and in particular restaurants whose
owners have suffered so grievously
they were only given a deduction
for others to use in business
their restaurant for two years this
two-year period must be withdrawn
which will allow the owners to obtain
financing
and get their restaurants back in
condition
congress can terminate it at a much
later date but two years
is not acceptable it's not enough now
this is where i
find trump to be saying some things
correctly and this is why the populist
rhetoric
can be so tricky and so pernicious trump
is saying six hundred dollars
isn't enough and there isn't enough for
small businesses like restaurants i
agree
that's correct but it's all wrapped up
in lies
and xenophobia but on that point i agree
and donald trump actually makes a couple
more good points
congress found plenty of money for
foreign countries lobbyists and special
interests
while sending the bare minimum to the
american people
who need it it wasn't their fault it was
china's fault not their fault i am
asking congress to amend this bill and
increase the
ridiculously low dollars
to two thousand dollars or four thousand
dollars
for a couple i'm also asking congress to
immediately get rid of the wasteful and
unnecessary items
from this legislation so trump wants two
thousand dollars
not six hundred dollars that number
happens to be
exactly what people like ro khanna
congressmen
have been asking for for months
including when trump claimed
oh democrats didn't negotiate he said
that at the very start of the speech
this is all backwards and along those
lines
trump now complaining about all these
countries getting money egypt etc
trump asked for those countries to get
money in
his budget but now he's saying the
problem is they're getting the money in
the covid bill
which they're really not they're getting
it in the bill that was voted on
in in conjunction with the covet bill so
it's all lies and then now trump on the
number of dollars
per person happens to pick the exact
number that many democrats were asking
for two thousand dollars and immediately
many democrats jumping and saying great
let we'll rewrite it right now and put
in two thousand dollars
that it doesn't republicans don't want
that but we're glad to do that
so trump is right on some aspects here
but he's a liar
and he's completely disingenuous and
then now the rap with donald trump
threatening to veto and he just can't
help himself
he has to throw in maybe he will
actually be the person sworn in
this january 20th and not joe biden and
to send me a suitable bill
or else the next administration will
have to deliver a coveted relief package
and maybe that administration will be me
and we will get it done thank you very
much
he cannot help himself he at any event
no matter what it's about he has to say
it might be me who gets that second term
on january 20th not joe biden so
the big picture is uh if trump does veto
it nobody gets a penny and that's the
risk right now
let's call trump's bluff trump says he
wants two grand
rewrite the bill democrats say you want
to do the two grand and
put it on republicans to say no if trump
really is serious about he wants two
grand per person
democrats are ready to do it and make it
be mitch mcconnell
or whoever is going to come out and say
no no no we don't want to do the two
grand so
we'll see what the next 24 hours bring
if this ends up getting people 2 000
instead of 600
even as disingenuous and dishonest and
clueless as trump is
i'll be i'll be glad and remember i'm
getting zero i'm not negotiating for
myself i'm not getting any money from
this but remember there were two bills
here
funding government and covid and uh if
it's vetoed
not only do people get nothing we may
even end up with another government
shutdown
who knows what happens then in terms of
transition
in terms of so many different things uh
but we'll
we'll we'll deal with that if and when
it becomes an issue remember
that on january 1 2021 we have a one day
membership special going on if you've
been thinking of grabbing a membership
at jointpakman.com
but you want a completely disgusting
immoral discount with which to do it
uh 1121 is the day if you want to be
notified of this great membership
special just uh get on our newsletter
you can sign up at davidpakman.com
and january 1st you will get a perfect
email from me
telling you exactly how to sign up the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the best way to support the david pakman
show
is to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com not only will you get
commercial free audio and video feeds
of the entire show every day no waiting
for youtube clips to publish
you'll also get the daily bonus show in
audio and video formats an extra show
there's a whole other show
behind the curtain for our members sign
up at joinpackman.com uh okay
donald trump has started the pardons
while he's continuing the pardons
speculation for several weeks about
exactly when
a flurry of pardons and commutations
would come from donald trump speculation
continues about
the pre-emptive pardons trump is said to
be considering for rudy giuliani
and his children his son-in-law jared
kushner
and many many others but there are now
15 or so more pardons and commutations
issued yesterday by donald trump now as
far as the russia probe
remember the one that led to all sorts
of arrests and indictments
um donald trump has pardoned his own
former
foreign policy adviser george
papadopoulos
who was found guilty of lying to federal
investigators as well as alex
vanderzwaan who was the dutch lawyer who
also lied to investigators
in connection with the russia
investigation so slowly but surely
donald trump is pardoning everybody who
is wrapped up in the mueller probe it's
a sort of revisionist
history the the investigation did find
lots of crimes they like to claim
it didn't but in any case trump will
just keep pardoning everybody
and in a way retroactively wipe the
slate clean even those folks were
convicted and a pardon uh a part of
you know this is a kind of a bigger
legal debate but if you're pardoned then
you're conceding you were guilty now you
could say well it was an unfair guilty
verdict and you can make that case
a donald trump also pardoning former
republican congressman duncan hunter
former republican congressman chris
collins
four blackwater mercenaries involved
in an iraqi massacre that's an entire
other story we previously covered
two border patrol agents convicted in
2006
for shooting and wounding an unarmed
undocumented immigrant and then actually
covering it up
just a horrible signal that that sends
trump con
pardoned several people convicted of
non-violent drug crimes who were serving
long sentences that i agree with
trump also pardoning alfonso costa
a dentist who pleaded guilty to health
care fraud
alfred lee crum who pleaded guilty
to illegally distilling moonshine 70
years ago
weldon angelos who was sentenced to 55
years
for selling marijuana and carrying a
handgun
a philip lyman county commissioner in
utah who was sentenced to 10 days in
jail
because of his uh protest on atv
restrictions on federal land
okay and otis gordon who was convicted
of possession with intent to distribute
also philip s formus a florida nursing
home mogul
convicted for paying bribes in a
medicare
fraud case also had some of his sentence
commuted by trump
and in addition to the pardons a number
of commutations the remaining prison
term of former
congressman steve stockman that's the
texas republican convicted
for almost two dozen felonies including
fraud and money laundering
and trump saying that because stockman
is 64
with underlying pre-existing conditions
he's at greater risk
during covid and he already got covered
while in prison what's interesting about
that is
trump says hey i'm good now because i
got coveted but even though
this guy already got coveted and
recovered it's still a reason to pull
him from prison
a little bit incoherent but it is trump
after all so the big picture here
is number one this is likely to be just
the start of donald trump's pardons
number two this is a separate
uh path it's a separate topic um
than the pre-emptive pardons being
considered
for his family members people like jared
kushner
ivanka don jr eric trump and we've
learned over the last seven to ten days
the possible reasons they would benefit
from a preemptive pardon
jared kushner potentially already being
investigated
for creating this shell company through
which
hundreds of millions of dollars in
campaign donations may have been
laundered
rudy giuliani reportedly talking to
trump about a preemptive pardon etc but
here is the clear trend and actually
listen to this data point
harvard law school professor jack
goldsmith looked at trump's pardons
so far and found that 88
of the pardons so far are for people
either personally
tied to trump or people whose actions
furthered trump's political aims or
protected him in some way
now presidents have absolute pardon
power we know that
trump has repeated that often it's not
really in question legally speaking the
issue here
is that it's always more corrupt with
trump
so many of the pardons are for crimes
committed by people
connected to trump or even people who
helped trump by the crimes they
committed including lying to
investigators
ostensibly to protect donald trump in
the mueller probe
so we can have a broader debate about
pardons in general
and we've had that debate and that's not
really the topic here
with trump there's always he's able to
dial up the corruption and cronyism just
a little bit
or even significantly and that's exactly
what he's done here and we'll
wait and see what the full list of
pardons is uh this is super
interesting our old friend andrew yang
who ran
for the democratic presidential
nomination this year
is already leading a poll for new york
city mayor
even though he's not running yet and
there's been a movement to draft andrew
yang to be new york city mayor he's not
yet a candidate
and among democrats meaning within the
new york city democratic mayoral primary
andrew yang
is winning yang is polling 17 eric adams
polling
16 everybody else at 10 or below there's
another poll from a couple weeks ago
where it was andrew yang 20 with eric
adams who i believe is the
council i believe is the council
president in new york city
uh down at 14 so this is the 2021
election
uh the new york city mayoral election is
on november 2nd
2021 the primary is on june 22nd so
we're already only six months from the
new york city mayoral primary and in the
grand scheme of things that's pretty
soon it'll just be
five months once joe biden is
inaugurated now the current new york
city mayor bill de blasio
is term limited from running again and
this upcoming election is going to be
the first one in new york city using
ranked choice
voting so there's a bunch of very
interesting things
related to this uh it's very early the
polling is basically a tie within the
margin of error in this latest poll
and andrew yang hasn't even announced
and that's exactly what makes this so
interesting without even being a
candidate merely with the rumor of being
a candidate
this early andrew yang is already doing
really well now at the same time
even though andrew yang is not yet
running
he has signaled that he is likely to run
in a few different ways
first of all there are lots of people
claiming they've been told privately
that andrew yang
plans to run for new york city mayor
second there are people
saying that andrew yang has actually
decided to run
and is simply waiting for january maybe
after
joe biden's inauguration to make the
announcement
but andrew yang has been meeting with
some important new york city figures
corey johnson who's speaker of the city
council to talk about running
he's hired his advisors bradley tusk and
chris coffey who
advised michael bloomberg when michael
bloomberg ran for mayor
so i think this is very interesting for
a number of different reasons number
one andrew yang would bring up sort of
pragmatism to the office of mayor
that bill de blasio even for
as well intentioned as he may be i i
think lacks and i think that would be a
very interesting
uh aspect you know one of the critiques
of andrew yang is that
as president andrew yang's approach of
sort of like the
uh uh tech ceo um
consultant technocratic approach that
it's not well suited for
the president it actually may be well
suited for new york city mayor in some
ways which we'll dig into if indeed he
he announces number two there's going to
be many people
who if andrew yang does announce that
he's running for new york city mayor
who are going to say andrew yang's not
really progressive and
there are going to be other new yorkers
maybe not in the democratic primary but
i'm thinking of staten island
republicans who are going to say
yang is a socialist because he believes
in universal basic income which was one
of his main
uh uh sort of uh distinguishing policy
ideas
during the democratic primary so you're
going to have i mean listen it's no
different than with biden where
the the progressive left says biden's
not very progressive and the right says
biden's a socialist communist
venezuelan marxist stalinist whatever
it'll be even further exacerbated
because this is all
you know millions of people in a very
small geographical area so i think the
contrast will be very notable
and number three there's an interesting
identity story here as well andrew yang
would be only the second asian american
candidate to even run for mayor the
other was john lew
in 2013 and then number four
because andrew yang has such nationwide
name recognition
it would be very interesting to see how
beneficial that is in
a new york city race new york city mayor
is one of the least local local races
because people and companies from all
over the country even all over the world
have a vested interest a financial
interest in many cases and who is mayor
of new york city
typically for business related
considerations
what i wonder if andrew yang has thought
of and he probably has
i i would imagine he has been thinking
about it is that new york city mayor is
a job
where almost no matter what you do
you are going to have a large swath of
new yorkers furious with you about the
job that that you've done
with some very rare brief exceptions
like rudy giuliani after 9 11
new york city is so diverse politically
economically racially uh in all ways you
know from bronx
queens the manhattan crowd even within
manhattan staten island the most
conservative part of new york city
uh there's a large swath of the
population that's almost always furious
with the new york city mayor
you are one of the most powerful local
officials in the country as new york
city mayor
you run a government larger than many
states as new york city mayor
and it comes with some horrible
realities that the mayor is always being
ripped apart
but in the end it's not that different
from being president when half the
country hates you
but geographically again the hate is in
a much smaller area and it's around all
the time
i'm sure andrew yang can handle it every
expectation is that we'll hear from him
next month about whether or not he
decides to run
and many reports that it's a foregone
conclusion that he's running he simply
is waiting to announce so
let me know your thoughts i think it's
there were ideas of what about if he
runs for governor somewhere
uh what if andrew yang runs for senate
somewhere
but new york city mayor is very
interesting and i'd be curious to hear
your thoughts about it
and we'll have more coverage about
andrew yang's possible
nyc mayoral run and all of the stories
from today's show
on the david pakman show instagram page
find us at david pakman show all one
word on instagram
and you can find me on instagram at
david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in
cherry ice flavor lucy is affordable
it'll ship right to your door you don't
have to go out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
welcome back to the david pakman show
the situation with donald trump's legal
team is becoming more
of a uh soap opera than anything i
recall
seeing over the last 25 years relating
so directly to the president of the
united states
donald trump's former lawyer
and almost special counsel sydney powell
is now
claiming she's been banned from the
white house
um i don't know whether to start with
the new part or
let's start with the new part and and
then we'll go backwards and i'll catch
you up on everything so listen to this
uh sydney powell telling fox news
she's been banned from the white house
and from speaking to trump check this
out
this is during an interview on fox news
where anchor john roberts is
interviewing
republican strategist karl rove is
general flynn's attorney sydney powell
who suggested after a meeting on friday
night she's been banned from the white
house in a statement to fox news saying
i've been blocked
by white house counsel and others from
seeing or speaking to the president
since i raised the public formal
findings and even more evidence of
foreign interference
from iran and china i'm told that she
still has the ability to call the
president she's not on any kind of
do not admit list at the white house but
i do know
that there are many people in senior
positions at the white house
who would prefer that ms powell and
others stay away from
okay so now that we've seen that you
really have to understand the back story
to comprehend the level of absurdity
that that is going on here so
shortly after the election donald trump
tweeted about sydney powell as one of
the lawyers representing him
uh he tweeted on november 14th rudy
giuliani
joseph de geneva victoria tensing sydney
powell
and jenna ellis a truly great team added
to our lawyers and representatives very
clear trump says sydney powell's part of
my team
great shortly after that sydney powell
joined donald trump's lawyer rudy
giuliani and jenna ellis and others
at this bizarre basement press
conference where they made all sorts of
uh very unusual claims none of them
based in fact and this is
the major press conference at which
sydney powell
started making the radical claims about
hugo
chavez antifa and george soros were part
of a plan to steal the election for
trump and this was
so crazy that it got the trump campaign
to put out a statement
basically distancing from and and sort
of like firing sydney powell
saying sydney powell is practicing law
on her own
she is not a member of the trump legal
team she is also not a lawyer for the
president
in his personal capacity so it seemed
sidney powell
was out if she was ever in which trump
said she was
she was then out per the trump campaign
until
last friday she shows up at the oval
office and she's the one talking to
trump about
maybe martial law maybe we seize voting
machines and all sorts of other
wacky ideas as well as reportedly
telling others in the room who were
saying you know
sir that's illegal saying you guys are
quitters
that made instant headlines because
number one
it's nuts and number two supposedly
trump
was distanced from sydney powell so how
is she in the oval office and how is she
potentially going to be made special
counsel and then now this
which is sydney powell says she's been
banned from the white house
and from speaking to trump and now
they're all going after her here's
another clip of karl rove during his uh
same interview with fox news just
bashing sidney powell
this pal has peddled theories that have
little basis in fact
uh the idea that hugo chavez from the
grave
was somehow involved in stealing this
year's election and that
i mean she was poured out in a courtroom
recently where
all of her expert witnesses which you
know one of them was so
uh highly prized that he had to have a
code name and couldn't be revealed that
he was a
she sold him as a highly you know expert
military intelligence analyst
turned out to be a mid-level computer
programmer from dallas
who couldn't even pass the entrance
exams for the 305th
intelligence brigade in intelligence
school
he couldn't even pass the exams and he
was her high level advocate
she had another expert who couldn't tell
the difference between
election precincts and townships in
minnesota and michigan
and claimed at 151 percent turnout in
wayne county michigan when any idiot
with access to google and the and the
county election returns could have seen
that the turnout was 51 percent
not 151 i mean what she has done
to sort of you know throw mud on the
president
through her addicts is unbelievable the
president has been so ill served by this
crowd
and and she's chief among them what i
absolutely love about
this is that karl rove is absolutely
right
in his criticism of sydney powell but
the things that rudy giuliani
and jenna ellis have been peddling are
only
marginally less crazy than what sydney
powell has been saying
karl rove and john roberts now are
framing this as whoa
sydney powell's nuts but actually
they're all nuts
and their work is totally worthless
and going nowhere but it's funny
and it's sad and it's a bizarre soap
opera that seems never to end
but it actually will end relatively soon
it'll it'll be much better for the
country now there's lots of
i've been seeing so many different legal
commentators and lawyers
saying the behavior of rudy giuliani
sydney powell and jenna ellis before
a variety of courts over the last month
month and a half really does warrant uh
complaints to bar associations and
that these are the types of actions that
should should really get somebody
disbarred
um i don't think it's likely that that
will happen but understand that
these figures have crossed over from
being
like i guess what we would call legal
lawyers into being
almost like cult activist type figures
where even if they were to be disbarred
for the things that they've been doing
at this point they can launch off into
being
tv lawyers for all sorts of right-wing
groups
or radical organizations or reactionary
movements so
it's almost irrelevant at this point
although i don't think it's a
uh it goes beyond the facts to say how
how could these people even really still
hold
uh bar association licenses but that
that's probably more of a story for post
inauguration
uh there's something interesting going
on within the evangelical christian
movement
which is that to uh to some degree
prominent evangelical christians have
started to
sort of turn on donald trump or at least
acknowledge that it's it's time to go
buddy
90 year old extremist evangelical
televangelist leader pat robertson of
700 club fame
accurately assesses the cult of
personality around donald trump and says
it's time to move on you really have to
see this to believe it
and there's an interesting irony here
which i'm going to discuss after
discuss with you after we look at this
first clip i think it's all over
i think the electoral college has spoken
i think the
the biden uh corruption uh
has not totally been brought to
uh fruition but it doesn't seem to be
affecting the electoral college
and i don't think the supreme court is
going to move in to do anything
and i think we're going to see a
president biden
and i also think we'll be seeing a
president
campbell harris not too long after the
inauguration of president
biden with all his talent and the
ability of
to raise money and draw large crowds
the president still lives in an
alternate reality
he really does people say well he lies
about this than the other but no he
isn't lying
to him that's the truth he had the
biggest crowd on
inauguration gay he had he had more
people than ever
he was the most popular of people uh he
saved nbc
but with the apprentice you go down the
line of things that
really aren't true and you know people
kept pointing to them but because they
loved him so much
and he was so strong for the
evangelicals the evangelicals were with
him all the way
but there was something about him that
was good
that god placed him in that office for
the time he's done a marvelous job for
the economy
but at the same time uh he is very
erratic
and he uh he's fired people he's fought
people and he's insulted people and
keeps going down the line
so it's it's a mixed bag and i think
it would be well to say uh you've had
your day
and uh it's time to move on what i love
about this
is that the same cult of personality
that pat robertson identifies as
surrounding donald trump
the same narcissism that pat robertson
identifies trump is suffering from
it's identical to both the followers
of evangelical cult leader types like
pat robertson and of the fall of the
leaders themselves
uh we we wonder you know does trump
believe he's a liar
or does he know he's lying the cultish
answer would be
you know eventually cult leaders become
so deluded
that what may start as things they know
to be lies
they end up kind of believing their own
lies or or at least
if they know they're lying they believe
they're lying for the right reason
because the means justify the ends or
they're telling some bigger truth if
they don't focus on the minutia
these are really common uh thought kind
of paradigms or mental models i think is
the right term
for cultish leaders of all kinds and
when pat robertson says trump believes
the lies
i suspect that the same applies to many
evangelical cultists like pat robertson
and others we've covered
they believe that the world is better
off when people donate to them
so that they can buy a private jet
because the private jet better allows
them
to go and spread the gospel or whatever
it is that that they claim to do
they get to a point where they have to
mostly believe their own lies in order
to continue living
a semi-coherently on just like a
day-to-day practical level
but pat robertson is mostly accurate in
his analysis of critique
and critique of trump it's just that
most of the analysis would apply
as accurately to himself and to other
evangelical televangelist types like pat
robertson
it's actually incredible though that pat
robertson
would accuse others of being in an
alternate reality
because pat robertson is a guy who has
said that the following
list of things can be demonic okay the
pat robertson says trump's in a fantasy
world pat robertson has said
second-hand sweaters can have demons
attached
ouija boards can be demonic yoga
is demonic harry potter feng shui
karate horoscopes the twilight series
actually you know what the twilight
series could be demonic but other than
that this list is crazy
paintings of buddha tv shows about
ghosts halloween just writ large
psychics young girls who do levitation
during sleepovers
and sometimes even a duh even adopted
children from other countries can be
demonic
according to pat robertson and pat
robertson says
trump's living in an alternate reality
what a world we live in isn't it now one
other funny thing
i didn't know until yesterday that pat
robertson's son
is part of the grift gordon robertson
this is a new i i guess this is maybe
the the sort of like
televangelist heir to pat robertson a
gordon robertson
who is pat robertson's son is also
involved with the 700 club and he also
seems to have turned on donald trump
here's gordon robertson a few weeks ago
saying
he doesn't think the trump legal team is
is making any sense with what they're
doing
gotta ask you if if they're not going to
go forward with proof
in these press conferences shouldn't
they just shut down the press
conferences why
why why have them i i'm looking at this
it's a complete disaster for trump and
and why is he even doing it they have
had other press conferences there's the
famous
four seasons total landscaping uh it
just doesn't seem
it doesn't seem to be helping whenever
they get in front of the cameras it just
doesn't seem to be helping
again the the question is always let's
see the evidence but
without people sort of buying in that
there's
evidence of widespread fraud if you
don't have that
and you have state legislatures coming
in and saying we're going to invalidate
the
vote totals and vote our own slate of
electors
uh in so that uh our team gets to win
uh aren't aren't you really playing with
fire i mean at that point in time
does anyone trust our democracy anymore
i mean
all the allegations that uh we're
looking at
um dictatorship that we're looking at
overthrowing democracy
all of those allegations come to the
fore and i would predict you'd see
rioting in the streets
how insane is that pat robertson and
gordon robertson both saying trump's
wacky while they are completely wacky
fascinating to watch and i i my
instinct is that this
seeming realignment um is going to
disappear very quickly and everything
will go back to where it was much like i
said
um that republicans are going to sort of
uh forget about trump once trump
disappears and
who what trump i don't know we we're
here about we're here to lower the dead
and prevent socialism or whatever
i assume that the evangelical
televangelist types
that have started to see a little bit of
reason um
are going to go right back to the same
stuff joe biden's very demonic
and and so on uh very quickly that
that's my prediction
remains to be seen whether it happens
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
you know um i thought that when we hit
1 million youtube subscribers a couple
of months ago
i thought things would calm down i think
uh i
i believed everything would normalize
with a sam cedars show the majority
report
and just as a disclaimer this is just a
joke it's just a break from
the serious stuff on today's show but
let's pretend that this this is for real
um i was expecting that we would get
past
this silly spat with the majority report
i never considered
that we were even in a battle with sam
to get to a million subscribers i think
the battle was
was mostly going on in sam's head quite
frankly and
it might have been placed there by a
caller to both of our shows named
ronald ray gunn and possibly even by
hugo chavez nicholas maduro
and cuba but in any case sam thought
there was a race to a million
subscribers and to the extent that there
was
sam lost that race now the race didn't
exist
i wasn't participating in it but sam
lost the non-existent race we didn't
participate but we hit a million
subscribers
and then we hit 1.1 million subscribers
and now we have surpassed
1.2 million subscribers and now good for
sam
okay please remember i'm on sam's team
i want what's best for the movement not
just me
now finally sam cedar
is approaching one million subscribers
on youtube
and i am the first to be here and issue
a pre-emptive a blanket congratulations
to sam
on very very soon hitting a million
subscribers now
everything was going beautifully until
yesterday a viewer gets in touch with
sam
and suggests that dominion voting
systems
may be counting youtube subscriptions
and that exactly the same foul play
alleged in the 2020 presidential
election
can be blamed for the david pakman show
youtube channel
hitting not just 1 million subscribers
before sam but
1.1 and 1.2 million subscribers before
sam
and sam doesn't even challenge this on
his program even
he seems to take pleasure he has this
like satisfied grin on his face
when this is brought up take a look at
this youtube contracts dominion to count
subscriptions
so uh so many people have subscribed to
the majority report that it broke the
algorithm
and sent your subs to david pakman this
explains why he is not the one million
and he was born in south america so you
know so it doesn't matter yeah
it's like john mccain running for
president well no i'm saying there's a
connection there to be made
oh okay yeah oh right i forgot our
initial scheme here it was all about
venezuela interfering even bringing up
my south american heritage
is is actually that's very low that
that's ugly
uh i'm i'm shocked quite frankly that
sam
sam chose not to challenge those claims
no mickey seems to revel in it
she actually seemed to think that there
was something funny here now as a
reminder this
is just a joke we're friends with sam
and sam's doing great
and he's soon going to be when sam hits
a mill now this is serious
when sam hits a million subscribers he
will be the fourth
independ the independent progressive
news type show
on youtube to get to a million
subscribers tyt
of course the big player with 5 million
subscribers i believe
we're at 1.2 million brian
tyler cohen recently made it over the
line and is over 1 million and sam
cedar about to enter the one million
subscriber club
and we're looking forward to welcoming
him but remember
this is not zero sum you can subscribe
to sam
and to us and to tyt and to whoever else
you want to subscribe to so please do
um i've got nothing to sell you here
other than a free good time
we're at 1.2 million we're almost 200
000 youtube subscribers ahead of where
we wanted to be and hoped to be by now
we
have the possibility of getting to one
and a quarter that's 1.25 million
subscribers
by uh january 1st if you help us so
let's make it
i've got nothing to sell you here i mean
listen i have things to sell you i'm not
selling them to you right now
here i'm just saying participate
subscribe to all of these channels
and uh if we can say one thing about
2020
it's that the growth that progressive
independent media has experienced and
there's two reasons for it
one is the pie is actually getting
bigger
i was interviewed not long ago by uh
professor richard wolff
my former professor on his program
and one of the things that's going on is
that more people now
default to looking on youtube for
analysis and commentary so the pie is
getting bigger
but also certainly awareness
of programs like ours sam's the young
turks and lots of others has been
growing so
let's uh keep it going into 2021. all
right
i'm going to have to sort of issue an
apology here uh we have a voicemail
number that number is 219
to david p uh i am causing huge
problems for one of our viewers
uh with his fiancee take a listen to
this
hey david my name's danny this is the
first time i'm calling in
but i've been a listener for a few years
now and um i was really just calling
to ask uh kindly for you to dial back
on the reasonable and wise takes right
it's starting to cause some jealousy
issues with my fiance
that i listen to you so often so sorry
um and not only
politics but um also your assessment of
pies and
apple pies especially right um i think
the only
major disagreement i've had lately has
been with your take on sweet potatoes as
quote
the perfect vegetable um in fact
i submit to you that in fact bell
peppers are the perfect species oh my
god
clean them out you can eat them like an
apple they taste great they're not
annoyingly spicy they're crispy you can
stuff them and bake them oh dear anyways
i just need for you to dial back on the
stellar opinion pieces
you're handing out media literacy like
it's candy on halloween
and uh you're also the biggest reason i
voted i was
i'm a very supporter but that's
important biden thanks to you
so um for the sake of my happily ever
after would you please just
cut it out yeah listen um i i apologize
that your fiance is getting jealous and
and all of that um but so here
a bell pepper is the is better than a
sweet potato and
i i'm not anti bell pepper in any way
but but when you're cooking you dip
you dip a bell pepper in some hummus
that's great but
in cooking a jalapeno okay you're adding
a little heat but
a bell pepper is not dramatically
different than an onion in that it gets
soft and absorbs the flavor of whatever
is there
sweet potato brings so much more to the
table from the standpoint of flavor
from the standpoint of nutrition from
the standpoint of of caloric density
and i just read a fascinating i have
loved
sweet potatoes since i was a little kid
when i was first sampling
baby food uh back in 1984 i guess 85.
uh no 84 it would have been um when i
first got my first taste of sweet potato
um my eyes lit up it was an it was an
incredible day
and uh you know a lot of people think
because a sweet potato has the word
potato in it that it's
it's like a potato it has nothing to do
with a potato understand that potatoes
are the stems
of a plant whereas sweet potatoes are
the root
or some say the root i say root um
the uh it's a totally different family
it is uh a potato and a sweet potato
could not be more different and by the
way
all these people in the u.s who
interchangeably talk about
a sweet potato and a yam uh i don't know
that i've ever seen a yam an
actual yam in the united states yams are
gigantic
compared to sweet potatoes they look
different let's stop
miss naming sweet potatoes as yams
anyway i could go on for probably an
hour about sweet potatoes
but the the mere idea that a bell pepper
is going to hold a candle to sweet
potatoes i find that offensive but
otherwise i love the praise i love that
this caller voted thanks to the show etc
etc
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we'll talk about rudy giuliani's
slippery cell phone
we will talk about the vatican's
position on vaccines for the virus
that use abortion cell lines hint
they're okay with it
and deborah burks is going bye-bye when
joe biden
transitions in because she's retiring
and we'll talk about what we think is
behind that
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com and get
instant access to the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to
an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save
20 percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman steadymd lets
you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any time over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99 dollars a month
with no
other fees or copays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started